>> Sean: AS WE MENTIONED IN
OUR MONOLOGUE, WE OBTAIN NEW
UKRAINIAN DOCUMENTS FROM RUDY
GIULIANI.
THE DEMOCRATS EARLIER TODAY
ACTUALLY WENT INTO A BRIEFING
ROOM.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO
GET IMPEACHABLE EVIDENCE ON THE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT THEY GOT HIS INFORMATION
THAT HURT THEIR CAUSE AND SHOWED
ABOUT, OH, THE DEMOCRATS AND,
YEAH, THE DNC AND
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN, THEY
WERE COLLUDING WITH UKRAINE IN
2016 AND, YEAH, THEY ARE
ADMITTING THEY TRY TO HELP
HILLARY CLINTON AND ALSO
ADMITTING THE INFORMATION THEY
PROVIDED HAD AN IMPACT ON THE
RACE BECAUSE THEY TOOK DOWN PAUL
MANAFORT WITH THAT INFORMATION.
WE ALSO HAD RUDY GIULIANI
THREATENING TO SUE ALONG WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND THE PRESIDENT
WE NOW LEARN THE FORMER
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR RUDY
GIULIANI INTERVIEWED THE FIRE
PROSECUTOR BY BIDEN, THAT WILL
BE THE PROSECUTOR SHOKIN.
HE'S HERE TO EXPLAIN ALL THAT.
MR. MAYOR, THE DEMOCRATS HAD A
BAD DREAM BECAUSE THEY ALL
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO COME TO
FRUITION TONIGHT.
IT DID NOT.
YOU INTERVIEWED SHOKIN AND THEY
MAY SUE.
IT'S A LOT TO DIGEST.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TODAY, THE BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT YESTERDAY WAS THE
IG, THE STATE DEPARTMENT WAS
GOING TO GO OVER AND GIVE ALL
THE SECRET DOCUMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE.
AND THE COMMITTEE, I GUESS, THEY
WERE SITTING THERE FIGURING OUT
HOW THEY CAN DO IMPEACHMENT
BASED ON NOTHING AND WHAT THEY
GOT SHOVED DOWN THEIR THROATS,
IT'S A COMPLETE, TOTAL
ABSOLUTELY TERRIFIC
PROSECUTORIAL OUTLINE OF WHY
JOE BIDEN IS SO GUILTY.
IT'S A JOKE FOR ME TO DESCRIBE
IT TO YOU.
WHAT I DID -- FIRST OF ALL, IT
DEMONSTRATES -- I PROSECUTED --
WELL, MAY BE A FREUDIAN SLIP --
I INVESTIGATED ALL OF THIS IN
2017 AND I FINISHED IT BY
MARCH 2019.
IT'S SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE ALL OF
THIS WAS DONE WHILE THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION WAS STILL
SPENDING, WHILE I WAS SEEKING IN
THE BEST TRADITION OF BEING A
LAWYER, A DEFENSE LAWYER,
VINDICATING MY CLIENT.
THIS IS -- I DIDN'T GO LOOKING
FOR JOE BIDEN.
THE UKRAINIANS BROUGHT ME
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE OF
UKRAINIAN COLLUSION WITH
HILLARY CLINTON, THE DNC, GEORGE
SOROS, GEORGE SOROS' COMPANY.
THEY PUT IT IN MY LAP.
THEY CAME AND GAVE ME TESTIMONY.
I WROTE IT OUT, I HAD A
PROFESSIONAL INVESTIGATOR MAKE
FBI 302S OF IT.
ULTIMATELY IT WAS JOHN SOLOMON,
WHO SHOULD GET A PULITZER PRIZE,
BY THE WAY, PUT THEM ALL ON
TAPE, SO IT'S ALL MEMORIALIZED
ON VIDEOTAPE.
THIS IS AS SOLID AS IT CAN GET.
I INTERVIEWED THEM.
IN ONE CASE, I INTERVIEWED ONE
SO BADLY THAT HE THOUGHT HE WAS
BEING CROSS-EXAMINED.
I DIDN'T DO WHAT THIS PONY
WHISTLE-BLOWER DID.
THIS PONY WHISTLE-BLOWER IS
GIVING HEARSAY EVIDENCE.
HE'S SAYING I'M NOT A DIRECT
WITNESS.
OKAY, YOU LIST.
GOODBYE.
I HAVE WHAT'S CALLED AN
AFFIDAVIT.
THIS IS NOT WHAT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER DID.
UNDER OATH, SIGNED UNDER
VICTOR'S SHOW
CAN.
VICTOR SHOW CAN TOLD ME HE'S
MORE THAN WILLING TO COME
TO AMERICA AND TESTIFY TO POINTT
TO AMERICA AND TESTIFY TO POINTE
FINGER AGAINST JOE BIDEN AND HIS
SONS BUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
TODAY.
THEY ARE CORRUPT AS SIN.
IT'S LIKE THE NOSE ON YOUR FACE.
THE UKRAINIAN OLIGARCHY DID NOT
PAY FOR HUNTER BITE IS
NONEXISTENT SKILL.
HE PAID FOR THE VICE PRESIDENT'S
OFFICE AND IT WAS A GOOD DEAL.
HE GOT HUNTER BITE IN
BIDEN OFF THE
HOOK.
HE CAME TO UKRAINE AND PAID
$5 BILLION JUST FOR NEARLY
GIVING UP THAT SHE'S GOING
AROUND UKRAINE SAYING IT WAS
WELL AWARE THAT TO SPEND THE
MONEY TO DO IT.
IF ANYBODY WOULD CARE TO
INVESTIGATE, THEY COULD FIND
EVERYTHING I JUST SAID.
EXCEPT THE FBI DIDN'T
INVESTIGATE FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DIDN'T
INVESTIGATE FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF.
MY WITNESSES WERE AFRAID TO GO
TO THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WHICH ACTUALLY COME
TO ME, WAS LIKE LIVING IN AN
ALTERNATE UNIVERSE BECAUSE I --
YOU KNOW, I PROSECUTED PEOPLE
FOR FAR MORE DANGEROUS AND FAR
MORE DIFFICULT TO CATS IN THESE
IDIOTS.
I COULDN'T HAVE DONE IT WITHOUT
THE FBI.
I'M SO DISAPPOINTED HOW COMEY
HAS CORRUPTED THE FBI AND ON THE
SURFACE IT HAS NOT BEEN
PERFORMED IN THE WAY IT SHOULD.
I HATE TO SAY THAT.
I COULD NOT HAVE GIVEN THIS TO
THE FBI IN EARLY 2018.
AND THE BILL BARR WASN'T THERE
YET, SO THEY WOULDN'T GO TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
SO I GAVE IT TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, TURNED IT OVER
TO THEM, I GAVE THEM EYEWITNESS
NOTES.
I WAS HOPING THEY WOULD COME
BACK AND INTERVIEW ME.
I WAS SO HAPPY WHEN THE
SECRETARY TOLD ME THEY WERE
GOING TO INVESTIGATE.
FOR SIX MONTHS, I SAW NO SIGN OF
AN INVESTIGATION, THEY NEVER
INTERVIEWED ME.
WITHOUT MY KNOWLEDGE, MAYBE THEY
INTERVIEWED SHOKIN -- THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE THEY DID.
AND IF THEY DIDN'T, SOMETHING IS
WRONG AND IT'S BEEN TURNED OVER
NOW TO THE FBI.
IF YOU DON'T INTERVIEW AN
EYEWITNESS, WHO WANTS TO GO
UNDER OATH AND WANTS TO BE A
CONFRONTATIONAL ACCUSER, WHICH
IS WHAT THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSTITUTION
REQUIRES, YOU'VE GOT TO BE
WILLING TO FACE YOUR ACCUSERS.
YOU'VE GOT ME THROWN OUT --
YOU AND MR. MAYOR  --
>> YOU'VE GOT THE CASE AGAINST
THE SUN AND EVERYBODY KNOWS YOU
ARE CORRUPT, JOE.
THIS IS EERILY SIMILAR WHAT
HAPPENED IN CHINA.
IT'S A PATTERN.
LET'S GO TAKE A LOOK AT JAMES
BIDEN AND HOW HE WAS SHELLING
THE OFFICE OF SENATOR WHEN THIS
GUY WAS BACK IN THE SENATE.
THIS REMINDS ME OF A PATTERN OF
CRIMINAL CONDUCT THAT SPANNED
OVER ABOUT THREE DECADES, THAT
THE ROMULAN WASHINGTON PRESS
CORPS JUST LET HAPPEN AND DIDN'T
LOOK AT AND IF THEY PICKED IT UP
AT ANY STAGE OF THE WAY, THEY
PROTECT US AGAINST THIS
CORRUPTION THAT MAKES A MOCKERY
OF US IN UKRAINE AND CHINA.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, SO YOU
INTERVIEWED -- IF
DONALD TRUMP JR. DID ANY OF
THIS, IF DONALD TRUMP DID THIS,
THEY MIGHT ACTUALLY HAVE THEIR
FIRST REAL CHARGE AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE POLITICO -- WE HAVE ALL
THE EVIDENCE THAT THE DNC AND
HILLARY'S CAMPAIGN COLLUDED
AGAINST UKRAINE, THE MEDIA IS
DEAF, DUMB, STUPID AS THEY
ALWAYS ARE AND CORRUPT.
WE WERE TOLD WHY HE WAS FIRED
FOR THEY SAID FIVE SEPARATE
TIMES HE WAS FIRED BECAUSE HE
WAS INTERVIEWING, INVESTIGATING
BIDEN'S CORRUPT SON.
>> I DON'T MEAN THIS AS AN
INSULT BUT ALMOST EVERYONE IN
THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT WOULD
BE FIRED.
IF HE IS CORRUPT, HE'S VERY
QUITE GOOD AT IT, HE'S QUITE
POOR.
HE'S GOT A LOT OF DOUGH.
BIG CARS, LOTS OF MONEY.
SHOKIN IS LIVING IN A VILLAGE,
LIVING IN A COTTAGE.
HE'S HIDING, SCARED OUT OF HIS
MIND THAT THEY ARE GOING TO KILL
HIM.
NOT UP TO US TO INVESTIGATE BUT
IF YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UKRAINE MIGHT OUT ONE OF THE
RICHEST PEOPLE COME AND GET OUT
WITH $5 BILLION -- WHAT DO THEY
SAY IN "THE GODFATHER?"
FILLING HIS BEAK, I CAN'T
REMEMBER THE EXPRESSION.
IF YOU THINK HE GOT BIG MILLIONS
FOR IT, HE SHOULDN'T BE IN THE
INVESTIGATORY BUSINESS.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, WE ARE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
YOU SAY YOU MAY SUE.
WHO?
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT A VERY
SERIOUS LAWSUIT.
ADAM SCHIFF ADVANCE THAT LAWSUIT
TODAY WITH THE POSSIBILITY THAT
HE HAD ADVANCE KNOWLEDGE AND
ORCHESTRATED THIS NEWEST
NONKNOWLEDGE, NO FIRSTHAND
KNOWLEDGE -- THEREFORE SHOULD BE
IGNORED WHISTLE-BLOWER.
HE WOULD'VE BEEN IGNORED UNTIL
THEY CHANGE THE RULES.
NONE OF HIS TESTIMONY IS
ADMISSIBLE IN COURT, IT'S ALL
HEARSAY.
EVERY BIT OF SHOKIN'S TESTIMONY
IS NOT ADMISSIBLE.
ACTUALLY, SHOKIN TESTIFIED TO
REAL CORRUPTION.
EVERYTHING HE SAID ABOUT ME IS
FALSE.
MY MEETING WITH HIM WAS NOT SET
UP BECAUSE OF THE CONVERSATION.
DO YOU KNOW WHY, IDIOT?
IT WAS SET UP BEFORE THE
CONVERSATION.
THE TWO PEOPLE HE SAID I CALLED
I NEVER CALLED.
ONE OF THEM I WOULD'VE NEVER
CALLED BECAUSE HE WAS PUT ON THE
LIST OF CORRUPT PEOPLE THAT I
SHOULD NEVER TALK TO AND I HAD
TO HAVE PRETENDED KNOWLEDGE OF
IT.
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT WITH REGARD TO ME.
THERE ARE APPARENT INDICATIONS
THAT I COULD POINT OUT, SEVEN,
EIGHT, WHERE HE'S LYING.
HE MAY NOT BE LYING.
HE'S RELYING ON OTHER PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY HEARSAY EVIDENCE IS
INADMISSIBLE.
TERRY
I HAVE SIX WITNESSES WHO CAN
GIVE DIRECT ADMISSIBLE EVIDENCE
OF UKRAINIAN COLLUSION, NOT
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, PARTICIPATION
IN THE STEELE DOSSIER WITH PHONY
INFORMATION, A VERY CLEAR
CORRUPTION SCHEME BY THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF OUR
UNITED STATES THAT HAS TO BE
VINDICATED AND ALL OF IT WAS
EXPOSED BEFORE HE WAS A
CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT AND IT'S
NOT BECAUSE HE'S A CANDIDATE OF
PRESIDENT, BUT BECAUSE WE HAD
A CORRUPT, DISGRACEFUL
VICE PRESIDENT WHO DISGRACE OUR
COUNTRY IN THE UKRAINE, AND IN
CHINA AND THEY ARE STILL TALKING
ABOUT HOW CORRUPT HE IS AND
STUPID WE ARE FOR NOT CATCHING
IT.
HAS TO BE VINDICATED FOR THE
HONORARY UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
HE DISGRACED THEM.